PROFESSOR: Welcome back.
So in this session
we're going to cover
homogeneous constant coefficient
equations for any roots.
So we're told to
assume that z of t
is equal to exponential minus 3t
times cosine plus i of sine t.
And to assume that
this complex number is
a solution to this
differential equation, which
is second order with
constant coefficients m,
b, and k, which are real,
and from this assumption
give two real solutions
to this equation.
In the second part, we're asked
to find a general solution
for this other differential
equation, which
is the same form as
that seen in part a,
with now the real values for
b equals to 6, m equals to 1,
and k equals to 10.
And then we're asked
of this system that
would be captured by this
differential equation is
overdamped or underdamped.
In the last part we
switch gears and we're
given a series of
roots, eight roots
to an eighth degree
polynomial, and we're
asked to write down the general
solution for that polynomial.
Note that here we have repeated
roots, which is basically
where the trick is.
So why don't you
take a few minutes,
and we'll come back to
solve these problems.
Welcome back.
So for the first part,
we're given a complex number
clearly split into its real
part and its imaginary part.
So this is the
imaginary part of z,
and this is the real part of z.
Now, the differential
equation that we are given
is constant value-- differential
equation second order, linear,
and homogeneous.
So there is no right-hand side.
So clearly you can see that
if a complex number that
can be written as real
part plus i imaginary part
is a solution to this equation,
then both sides independently
are also solutions
to this equation.
So by giving us
this complex number,
we are actually given
two types of solutions
that we can then
write down as two
linearly independent solutions.
So the general solution to
this differential equation
can then be written in the form
of-- one constant coefficient
is undetermined, minus 3t
cos t plus another constant
coefficient minus 3t sine of t.
Where basically,
we're introducing
a linear combination of two
linearly independent solutions
that were just taken from
the original complex number
we were given.
So for the second
part now, we are
asked to find a general
solution for the ODE.
We'll just rewrite here for now.
So again, constant coefficient,
homogeneous equation.
And we're just asked to
find a general solution.
So we learned from
the class notes
that we can use the
characteristic polynomial
method to solve this equation.
And the characteristic
polynomial
here will have this form.
And basically, we
just need to find
the roots of this
characteristic polynomial
to be able then to
express the solutions
of this homogeneous constant
coefficient equation in terms
of function, exponential to
whatever roots we will find.
So I just want to write
down the discriminant
of this polynomial.
So what do we have here?
What was the question again?
So we're asked then to
just find the discriminant
for this equation.
So b squared minus 40,
which is basically minus 4.
So we have a discriminant
that is negative.
And the roots for our polynomial
here are just going to be...
the root absolute value
of the discriminant
with the complex number
i out, because we
had a negative discriminant.
So these couple of
solutions, plus or minus,
tell us that we are going to
have oscillations as solutions
for this differential
equation, and that it's also
going to be actually
damped oscillations,
because we have the
first-- the real part
of the number being negative.
So let me just write down
the pair of solutions
that we would have.
We will have this that comes
out of the real part, cosine.
I'll put the root
of 4 is just 2.
And so we have
cosine t, that's one.
6/2, of course, is just 3.
So here I switched directly
to writing them in cosine
and sine, in the forms.
But we could also have
kept it in the complex form
if we were solving the
equation in complex space.
And then we would just
have complex exponentials
here with the frequencies
omega-- angular frequency 1.
So this is the
homogeneous equation,
the homogeneous solution for
this homogeneous constant
coefficient
differential equation.
Now, what do we see?
We can see that it's exactly
the same form that the solution
that we had previously.
And so the question here is
this oscillator overdamped
or underdamped?
And as we see here, we're
going to have oscillations
that are damped by a pre-factor
of decaying exponential minus
3t for both cases.
So this is decaying.
So there is definitely damping.
And we can see that
here, because we
had a positive
value for b, which
is the damping term in
the oscillator system.
But there are
still oscillations,
because we had a discriminant
that was negative,
which introduced complex
numbers, hence cosines
and sines, so
basically, oscillations.
Therefore we're in the case
of an underdamped response,
an underdamped system.
The discriminant was negative.
So for the last part
of this problem,
we now leave this
differential equation,
which was second order, and move
to higher-order differential
equations of eighth order.
And we're given eight roots.
4 minus 5i.
We have the root of
3, which is real,
which is repeated three times,
and a root 4 plus or minus 5i,
which is repeated two times.
So we saw before then
when we have repeated
roots, that means
that we would have,
let's say, in a second-order
differential equation.
We would have in this
case a discriminant
that would be equal to 0.
And we would need to introduce
a different type of solution,
because instead of introducing
an exponential of plus r*t,
exponential minus r*t, now
we don't have the minus r*t.
So we need to seek
another type of solution.
And we'll multiply
the exponential by t.
So one type of solution for this
unique root that would come out
would be just 2t.
For the first of the tripled
root, it would be a 3t.
For the second one,
we would have t 3t.
For the third one, we need
to go higher order, 3t.
Now we have complex
roots, so that gives us
solutions of the same form that
we found in questions a and b.
So I'm going to just
write them here,
where now we have e^(4t)
cosine 5t plus e^(4t) sine 5t.
And for the repeated
root, it's the same game.
Even though we're in complex
roots, it's the same idea,
we need to multiply
all of it by t.
So these are the families of
linearly independent solutions
that would come
out of these roots.
So now the general
solution is simply
the linear combination of all
these linearly independent
functions.
So we will introduce
different constants.
c_5, c_6, c_7, and c_8.
And we have eight undetermined
coefficients to deal with,
because these would
be eight roots
of an eighth-order polynomial.
And so if we were to
solve an initial value
problems like that, we would
need eight different types
of initial conditions
to determine
the values of these constants.
So to summarize, we used the
characteristic polynomial
method to solve these
problems introducing
higher-order equations than
the first-order differential
equations we saw before.
And what is
important to remember
is that the different types
of solutions that you get,
depending on the roots of
the characteristic polynomial
and the sine of
the discriminant.
So whether the roots
are real or purely
imaginary or
imaginary numbers will
give three types
of the behavior:
the critically damped
behavior; if it's real
then it's going to be
just overdamped behavior;
and if the roots
are complex, then it
would be underdamped behavior.
Now when we are given
different types of roots,
with repeated roots
it's important to know
how to construct the
solutions as well.
And that's by introducing
new types of functions where
we're multiplying
by polynomial in t
in front of the exponential.
So that ends the
session for today.